الصدفه الخارقه للطبيعه قد تجعلك تلتقي
يوما ما بشبيهك ربما عند السفر او في
الطائره او حتى عند الذهاب الى التسوق قد
يختار البعض ان يجدوا اشباهم عبر تطبيقات
خاصه تمكنهم من العثور على اشخاص يتمتعون
بصفات شكليه توشى بهم
الدكتور منال الباحث في معهد جوزيف كاريرز
في برشلونه وجد ان الاشخاص المتشابهين
وفقا لبرنامج التعرف على الوجه يتشاركون
جينات اكثر بكثير من الاشخاص الاخرين
الذين اعتبرهم البرنامج اقل تشابك السؤال
هنا اذا كان لديك شبيه
هل سترغبون في مقابلته
[موسيقى]
طيب دكتور كيف كيف يعني انه احنا نتشارك
لهذه الدرجه مع اشخاص لا يقربون لا نحمل
نفس الدم ولا نحمل نفس الجينات ولكن
يشبهون شكلا الى هذه الى هذه الدرجه
من بدايه الخليقه الى الان هي الجينات
محصوره على 32 الف جيم
خلال
تطور انه في جينات تظهر وبعد اجيال تختفي
وبعد اجيال اخرى تظهر ثاني مره فمن ذلك
هذا اللي يسمونها الطفره الجينيه اللي
تظهر بين فتره وثانيه ولا لا تغيير بيجيني
يعني احنا متغير يعني ابائنا قبل اكثر من
200 سنه ما يحملون بالضبط نفس الجينات
اللي عندنا
ذلك ان في عوامل اخرى غير يعني ممكن انا
احمل الجنود عندك نفس الجن لكن هو تعبير
الوراث يختلف من عندي يظهر عليك بطريقه
مختلفه بالضبط
لانه في بعض العوامل لها اكثر من جينى مثل
التحكم في اكثر من 7 اللون البشره جنين
مسؤولين عنهم مو معنى انك ورضت جين واحد
معناها تكون نفس طيب هذا يدفع العلم الى
تطور بانه يمكن بعض الامراض التي تصيب شخص
من الممكن ان من خلال العثور على شبيه
الجيني او حتى
الظهور الجيل هذه على الشكل وشبيهي من
الممكن ان نستفيد منه
كخلاياك
تصحيح لامراض انا اعاني منها مثلا صحيح
ممكن التشابه الشكل ممكن يؤدي الى التشابه
الجيني فبالتالي مثلا نقل الاعضاء مثلا
الكيدي والليفر والاشياء هذه في حاجه
اسمها
الخليه واذا كان في تشابه جدا جدا كبير
يعني ممكن يطابقون
الكبد ولا ولا
على مستوى طيب دكتور هذا سؤال فضولي هيك
عندي ذكرت في بدايه حديثك بانه حتى نحن
كفصيله البشر نتشارك مع فصائل اخرى من
المخلوقات من هالفئران بنسبه كبيره من
الجينات وعشان هيك بستخدموها للبحث العلمي
واجراء تجارب عليها لانها تشبهنا نوعا ما
طيب هل هذا يمكن ان يفسر ليش في يعني
تقريبا كل البشر بيشبهوا نوع معين يا من
الحيوانات من الطيور من المخلوقات الاخرى
هل هذا هو التفسير هو التشابه انه الخالق
واحد والجينات واحده الموجوده بالانسان
الحيوان هي نفسها لكن
ليش
مشرد اقرب سنه
مختلف تماما عنه لكن بالرغم جينيا معروف
انه اكثر من 98% نسبه تشابه
[موسيقى]